il n'y a pas de mauvais livre il n'y a
pas de mauvais spectacle il n'y a pas de
mauvaise homme politique tout est
merveilleuse
un bonsoir j'ai 33 ans et tu rédacteur
en chef de l'être à spectacle télévision
à l'événement du jeudi j'ai fait une
émission sur FR3 qui s'appelait boîte
aux lettres que nous aimions beaucoup et
je vais te demander puisque c'est dans
l'air du temps pourquoi cette émission
avait été supprimée pour une raison très
simple et qu'à l'époque d'ailleurs avait
amusé les gens c'est que j'avais invité
parce qu'il y a de ma part une folie
François Léotard du temps était le
ministre de la Culture la boîte aux
lettres comme j'avais invité rallye de
Chirac ou d'autres et dans l'émission
j'avais aussi habité mon copain Pierre
Desproges
et c'était tout ça se passait la veille
des nominations des présidents de chaîne
par la par la CNCL
et des proches avaient en direct m'avait
dit quelle idée recevoir les retards
avait un joli à Léotard et avait dit
ensuite son fameux couplet sur Michel
Droit
qui va se moucher aux chiottes et qui
ressort je sais plus comment faire bon
les doigts plein de pistes ou je sais
plus quoi et ça fait gêné un peu ça
avait gêner un peu la des programmes à
des convoqué il m'avait donc supprimé
l'émission et interdit d'antenne c'est
une chose que je n'oublierai jamais et
surtout les stations de défaire 3 Pierre
Desproges jusqu'à sa mort donc mais tu
dis la direction des programmes c'est
qui c'était à l'époque l'endroit
Glandier qui est maintenant enfin qui
était
remplacé par un grand écrivain Georges
filiou et qui et qui avait considéré que
c'était un crime de majesté et qui a mis
d'ailleurs pierre des chemistafer sur le
qui a considéré que c'est à cause de ça
qu'elle n'avait pas été reconduite à la
direction des programmes bien sûr des
FR3 va vers plus de conformisme et pas
vers moi on n'a pas le droit écoute
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui ouvrons la
télévision de de l'après-midi jusqu'à
22h30 il n'y a pas de mauvais film il
n'y a pas de mauvais livre il n'y a pas
de mauvais spectacle il n'y a pas de
mauvaise homme politique tout est
merveilleux
j'ai du mal à imaginer moi j'avais fait
un truc à boîte aux lettres qui avait
choqué les gens et je comprends c'est
que quand on aimait pas un livre on jeté
par derrière ce qui était c'est pas mal
pour les livres un peu dur bon et pour
les techniciens aussi mais mais mais je
trouve que la la la formule qui consiste
à dire qui sort 20 livres par semaine et
qu'il y en a la moitié qui sont mauvais
ce qui est la vérité mais
maintenant tout le monde adore tout le
monde alors tu t'occupes du Masque et la
plume depuis quelques temps ça passe sur
France Inter le dimanche à 20h et tu dis
effectivement que c'est salutaire parce
que c'est carrément une émission on peut
dire ce qu'on veut par rapport à le
cuménisme ambiant c'est une émission où
chacun dise qu'il pense et c'est pas du
tout serpent pas du tout et à
qui dans ton équipe maintenant alors
masque la plume alors c'est c'est
différent selon les matières en cinéma
il y a il y a les il y a les habitudes
bon il y a plus Charan sol on va en
parler de chance il y a plus
malheureusement jolie Bory mais il y a
des gens fantastiques il y a Odile grand
que j'adore qui a des tira de
fantastiques il y a Jacques cyclier il y
a Philippe Colin le fort il y a
qu'est-ce qui est encore il y a Michel
Bouju il y a
à table en littérature ça dépend il y a
Françoise du coup j'en dis et volfroy
François mauricier Angelo ronaldi
Antoine de Gaudemar en théâtre avec Guy
Dumur il y a salino il y a un tas de
gens c'est c'est une émission
qui me fait signe c'est que c'est
enregistré au studio 105 de la Maison de
la radio et comme comme depuis 35 ans il
y a des gens qui avaient 105 bourré pour
assister à quoi à au parlotte de cinq au
librus qui disent du mal du tout en
général y compris des spectacles de
France Inter pendant une heure et avec
talent ça je trouve ça assez simple
alors il y avait charançois le masque la
pub il a fait des grandes heures du
Masque et la plume c'est tirade c'est
pas d'armes avec Boris c'est quelque
chose d'extraordinaire sa voix et toi tu
tu viens de faire un bouquin sur lui
parce que c'est un mec extraordinaire
effectivement d'abord il a je sais pas
moi quel âge il a 90 ans non il vient
d'avoir 26 décembre 90 ans c'est ton
troisième livre d'entretien
où il y a 236 auteurs qui ont et dont
j'ai écrit 12 pages qui sont pas mal
d'ailleurs très bien et dans ces et dans
ces 12 pages tu expliques justement que
tu veux pas écrire alors est-ce que tu
veux pas écrire parce que tu as peur de
te confronter à ce que tu critiques
parce que tu as peut-être trop lu ou
alors tu nous prépares secrètement un
essai ou un roman tu sortiras un jour
elles ont voilà je voulais pas dire le
voilà quelle est la raison de tout ça on
cherche en selle je vous dis à une chose
c'est que d'abord un c'est vrai que je
préfère faire des bons papiers avec des
mauvais livres ça c'est clair bon et
j'en fais beaucoup des papiers
je préfère faire des pompiers avec des
mobilisants vraiment première chose
deuxièmement c'est que je crois qu'on
peut pas faire ce métier de critiques
littéraires de critiques enfin bon de
journée sculpturales et on peut pas
juger partie bon tous mes confrères
leçon je les admire
toi comme les autres je n'arrive pas
à penser sérieusement qu'on puisse
dire ce qu'on pense chaque semaine sinon
chaque jour et en même temps aller
soumettre au confrères tous les ans sa
petite production qu'elle soit
d'ailleurs
je crois que c'est ce qui a gangrené ce
milieu les cadres peints
la fameuse les quatre casquettes par
exemple dans le milieu littéraire être
écrivain membre d'un jurilité air
critique littéraire et éditeur c'est
vers ces quatre fonctions sociales
différentes pendant de la littérature on
est le seul pays à juger ça normal à
trouver que c'est normal on peut être
les quatre à la fois tes poèmes
à un moment autrefois oui il y a pas
autrefois il y a 10 ans mais c'est
peut-être un homonyme non non
parce qu'ils sont très mauvais
e
j'ai acheté le stock
qui traîne vaut mieux les enlever des
bouquinistes
bon alors mouvant comme disait neuf il y
a quelques temps dans cette émission il
disait Jérôme maintenant il s'est mis à
cartonner il s'étonne que les gens lui
en veulent mais enfin qui continuent
donc on va faire une interview
[Musique]
on va commencer avec les gens dans tu
parles avec charanson dans ton bouquin
Aragon un grand poète un grand poète je
pense que je pense qu'il mon sentiment
c'est que si c'était pas trompé
politiquement toute sa vie politiquement
il répète un grand poète je pense qu'il
est parti de ces grands écrivains qui
ont besoin de l'erreur pour être de
grands écrivains c'est valable pour ça
aussi c'est surtout valable pour ça je
pense que je pense que ça par exemple
toutes ces grandes erreurs qui sont pas
de politique malheureusement
qui ont même parfois été littéraire que
c'est quelqu'un qui parce qu'il s'est
trompé a été un grand écrivain je suis
convaincu que les que quelqu'un qui
pense juste tout le temps et dans l'air
du temps n'est pas et peut-être un bon
journaliste mais un mauvais écrivain
très bien monter alors ce que je n'aime
pas c'est le décorum de sa de son œuvre
dramatique surtout qui correspond au
décorum de sa biographie avec là en
revanche des mensonges des mensonges que
je trouve inadmissible et puis des
dans tout ce que je n'aime pas
grandiloquence cette fausse littérature
latine néoplastique que je ne supporte
pas alors après ce dont tu parles avec
Charan sol on va passer au tien standard
c'est c'est
parce que ce genre de réponse ça fait
vraiment pardon
je lis tous les jours c'est vraiment
c'est mon moteur de chevet
j'adore tourner
Tournier une bonne paire de claques lui
ferait pas du mal
tourné a été a été à mon avis le
meilleur écrivain français
avec ces quatre cinq premiers livres
depuis
que tous les tous les grands livres où
il a pris un mythe une légende qu'il a
détourné les rois mages Robinson tout ça
bon ça c'était le grand Tournier depuis
ils sont au pastilles il va chercher la
légende de Gilles derey donc il fait
quasiment rien et puis petit à petit
tout d'un coup il y a cette apologie
insensée insensée de de
la misogynie il y a des choses
pseudo écolo sur la femme qui doit
accoucher sur la paille et il y a enfin
ce qu'il a dit à newswick mais qui est
dans son dernier livre qui s'appelle le
bien-être amoureux qui est à mon avis
tout ce que oui mais alors qu'il est dit
depuis longtemps il dit depuis longtemps
arrêtons de que les femmes arrêtent la
péridurale qu'elle qu'elle arrête
d'accoucher dans les hôpitaux parce que
les enfants sont naisses avec de lait
her donc c'est ce sont des enfants
dénaturés retrouvons les bons vrais
accouchements dans la forêt dans les
buissons sur la paille et
mais c'est pire que ça c'est une
pagatheux
pendant une heure c'est mon plus grand
je posais des questions je comprends
rien aux réponses et je reposais une
question je comprenais rien à répondre
c'est beaucoup trop intelligent pour moi
Kenya
Pascal Quignard c'est un vrai écrivain
qui a inventé son dernier roman et ce
qui fait qu'on n'a rien compris à mon
avis il y a un papier un peu dur que
j'ai fait sur lui je trouve que son
dernier roman est un roman trop
sophistiqué trop prétentieux mais je lui
ai consacré deux pages très méchantes
parce que je considère que c'est un
c'est un écrivain pour ça que sans
lesquels je ne le pensais pas j'aurais
fait 10 lignes comme sur Irène frein par
exemple Irène
Irène frein Irène frein et ben je ronge
mon frein voilà je m'en vais
Alexandre Jardin un garçon un garçon
charmant dont je n'ai jamais vraiment
aimé les livres je considère qu'il a
besoin d'un roi lighting
apparemment c'est pas assez je veux dire
de non c'est c'est à mon avis c'est
encore c'est encore le Biarritz de au
niveau du garnitz de la littérature mais
à part ça il est charmant minois il a
une jolie généalogie on a envie de
l'aimer mais c'est souvent le dernier
c'est catastrophique pour moi
catastrophique mais pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de inarritube abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu